um good morning to you um mr javid um
obviously we saw you at the news
conference yesterday i just want to play
this world health organization grab for
you and our viewers and then we'll talk
about it here we go
our recommendation is for isolation of
cases isolation and clinical care of
cases to continue because our goal is to
prevent onward spread and also the
quarantining of contacts we support
countries in reducing that time i don't
say abandon it but reducing that time
we're not doing that we're deciding to
get rid of it all together um no no not
quite so what we said yesterday was it
marked a new chapter in our fight
against the pandemic where we are
returning to plan a so that's what we're
doing and that's because plan b has
worked with the data shows that omicron
is now in retreat and it's worked for a
number of reasons but mainly because it
brought us the time that we wanted
to build our defenses and the best way
we did that across the country were some
15 million people came forward to get
boosted and i want to thank each and
every one of them for what they have
done to to help us fight this pandemic
and also all the nhs workers the
volunteers and what they did and it's
because of that that we're now able to
remove uh some of the the rules and
restrictions by returning to plan a so
it means that for example that we're no
longer encouraging people to work from
home from thursday next week there will
be no mandatory use of the nhs covid
pass or the use of face coverings but
and turning to that particular message
that we just heard we do still need to
of course remain cautious prevalences is
still high so we'd continue to recommend
caution some rules still stay in place
including the rule to self-isolate if
you are positive what happens after
march
we're not there yet that's a few weeks
away so we're not scrapping the
isolation
the prime minister said yesterday said
all these rules and as i've said a
number of times they remain under review
i'm confused are we scrapping isolation
all together by the end of march or not
we will decide as we get closer to march
based on the data at the time all the
decisions that we've made from the start
of this pandemic have been based on the
data and that's what you heard yesterday
because omicron is in retreat because
our plan has worked but as i say there
there is still because of the need for
continued need for caution there's
something that everyone can still do if
they haven't yet done it which is to get
vaccinated by the end of march or not
we we said we will review those rules
and we would like to see it scrapped by
the end of march but that decision will
be made closer to the time okay in the
press conference yesterday you compared
covid to flu did you really mean to do
that yes
why because
it it was an example of how we need to
learn to live with
hundreds of 1 000 people have died
we have the the impact of covert of
course has been the biggest challenge
this country has seen since the second
world war 150 000 people as you say more
than that now have died have died with
uh with a a you're being positive of
covid and and during that time we have
you know at a great cost to us to many
countries we've seen uh very sadly you
know thousands and thousands of deaths
but we have learned a lot about kovalev
given those figures that we both agree
on why is it appropriate to compare it
to flu because we need to learn to live
with it we sadly people die of flu as
well in a bad flu year you can sadly
lose about 20 000 lives but we don't
shut down our entire country and put in
place lots of restrictions to deal with
it we need to continue with our lives
with sensible appropriate and
proportionate measures the one thing we
learned about flu because it's been
around for far far far longer is that we
have annual vaccinations for older
people in particular for children as
well we have good advice we may well
have
some kind of annual vaccination i think
that's where we'll probably end up but
it's really difficult for anyone to say
exactly
what the
longer term where we will be but one
thing i did also say yesterday is is
covert is not going away
it's gonna it's going to be with us for
for many many years perhaps forever and
we have to learn to live with it and
what we have shown mainly because of the
vaccines but also because the new
treatments that we have the antivirals
we've got more antivirals per head than
any other country in europe the testing
infrastructure that we've built the
biggest testing infrastructure it is
these things that will allow us to live
with kovid absolutely minister but those
people then who were ridiculed for
comparing kovidge to the flow
they shouldn't have been ridiculed
well i don't did you ridicule them i've
never ridiculed them
okay so
several people did shall we well you
think that that was inappropriate to
ridicule people well look i think i
think with the flu i i think
it's
if at the start of covid when we had no
vaccines we had no testing
infrastructure we had no treatments
people were comparing it to flu that
would have been wrong of course it would
have been wrong but look where we are
today two years on especially here in
the uk the most boosted country in
europe the most anti-virals per head in
europe the biggest testing
infrastructure in europe it is why we
are the most open country in europe we
are i think i think i think we are
leading europe in in the transition from
pandemic to endemic and we're leading
the way in showing the world how you can
live with cocaine let's talk about what
happened in the house of commons
yesterday an image of uh christian
wakeford uh crossing the chamber
defecting in other words well is this
going to help
or hinder the prime minister
well i i don't see it that way i was sad
to see how sorry
i was sad to see uh christian go it's
never good it's never good for any
political party to see see one of your
own uh leave and defect in that way of
course it's it's not good news but it's
it's a decision for him but i feel sorry
for the people of berry south they voted
they know it conservative i think uh by
election would be welcome yeah the
people have been if there be one yeah
i'd be very happy with the by-election i
think christian should be happy with the
by-election i think he's supported by
elections in these circumstances in the
past and uh i think given that the
people of berries have rightly voted
conservative in 2019 they wanted to get
brexit done they want to see a strong
economy and and all of that and now
they've got an mp that's changed his
affiliation without their permission why
not give them a say so that's the
younger intake what about uh those that
have been there for almost longer than
god in the form of uh david davis let's
remind our viewers what he said
yesterday
i'll remind him of a quotation
altogether too familiar to him of leo
amory to neville chamberlain you have
sat there too long for all the good you
have done in the name of god god
what sort of blows that
well i i've known david davis for for
many years i've got huge respect for him
we don't always agree on on everything
and that is one thing i i don't agree
with him on uh the
damaging is it when an elder statesman
who's been there since margaret
thatcher's day stands up and says in the
name of god go it is damaging of of
course it is you know if you said to me
would i rather that he didn't get up and
elvis doesn't get up and say something
like that of course i wouldn't want to
to see that that's he's a decision that
he's made that the prime minister has
come to the house of commons you know
last week he's he's he's set out
and apologized set out what he
has happened but most importantly i
think is that he's asked for this
investigation to be done for the time
and space
to be given for it to be completed and
the facts to be established and once
those facts are established the prime
minister will come very quickly back to
parliament and submit himself to
scrutiny so david davis or anyone else
any other member of parliament can ask
them
whatever question they want the other
thing he could do is go for a vote of
confidence now so it won't be that death
by a thousand cuts which david davis has
talked about he can limp on potentially
until the end of the year or party
conference or whatever but if he's so
confident why doesn't he go for that
vote of confidence right now well i
think the the prime minister set out
you clearly that
after having rightly come to the house
and apologized that the next step should
be for the facts to be established i
mean i think everyone would be
interested in the facts and and that is
what sue gray
yeah right and and that's what i mean
that is what that is what uh she the
work that she is doing she should be
given the time and space it's her
investigation no minister should sort of
determine how quickly she does it or who
she speaks or who she doesn't speak to
that's a decision for her but once the
facts are established
then i think we can see how parliament
will respond do you have do you does he
have your complete support he has my
support does he have your complete
support yes he has my complete support i
serve in his cabinet okay um if a
serving prime minister given that if a
serving prime minister breaks the law
does he have to step down
well i don't want to talk about a
hypothetical situation sympathetically
because well i don't was your are you
asking me about this current prime
minister i'm saying does a serving prime
minister if he breaks the law have to
step down well if as a general point the
ministerial code is very clear if any
minister from the prime minister down
breaks the law of of course they
shouldn't continue to serve as a
minister
if this prime minister has broken the
law should he step down i what i've just
said is a general rule that applies to
everyone there's no exceptions to that
rule so if this prime minister just to
be people yeah look just to be clear if
this prime minister has broken the law
he should step down well look you're
very cleverly trying to get me into a
hypothetical situation i knew you'd say
that so i actually looked up
hypothetical and what it means
uh yeah an idea or explanation is
something that is based on a few known
facts but that has not yet been proved
to be true or correct we've got a lot of
facts that we can look at as far as this
prime minister is concerned including
photographic evidence of what he got up
to including him admitting that he broke
the rules albeit inadvertently ignorance
is no defense in the law
we don't have the full facts yet that is
that we
he says that he was there but he didn't
know he broke the rules but he didn't
know he was breaking the rules that's no
defense in law look we don't we don't
have the full facts and let me just say
this as well that i completely
understand
why millions and millions of people
across the country from what they have
seen already whether it's on the tv or
in their newspapers or wherever they've
seen it why they are so angered and
pained i completely understand that and
i share that anger and pain i i really
do you've lived it yourself
i've lived it myself and you couldn't
we i'm sure we all have and some of us
in in the in the most difficult of
circumstances you might if i think about
my constituents that couldn't go
to hospital to see dying relatives you
know this is
so this is a very very serious situation
and that is why i do think that the
facts need to be established and you
know and put out there and then people
can come to a judgment i get that but
you know we saw the prime minister with
his hang dog expression earlier on in
the week saying that he was sorry but he
didn't understand the rules had been
broken i put it to you that it doesn't
matter because that is no defense in law
and if a prime minister has broken the
law you've said he should go well
as i say the the ministry of code
applies to all of us and and and it's
it's right the the code
what it says and how you should conduct
yourself but in terms of okay this prime
minister didn't know but in terms of
this situation we need to establish the
facts and as i say the the prime
minister has come forward he's
apologized he's accepted that mistakes
have happened he's taken full
responsibility and has said he will take
full responsibility for whatever the
sugray report comes out with but the
facts need to be established first he's
even admitted himself he doesn't need
sue grey to tell him he's admitted
himself that he broke them but we don't
we don't we don't have the full facts
he's admitted to it he's pleaded guilty
the the the the report i think is is
going to be absolutely crucial in this
it's being done with someone with the
utmost integrity and respect and
independent civil servant and once that
report is published i think that whether
it's you your viewers parliamentarians
can react to it at that time okay let me
ask it this way then if sue gray decides
that the prime minister misled the house
should he step down that's a
hypothetical situation do we need to go
through hypothetical again because it's
not i'm not going to opine on what she
may or may not decide by the way i think
that would be inappropriate for any
minister because this is an independent
what would be
inappropriate to try and sort of guess
what may or may not
be the outcome of the world it's already
admitted that he broke the rules we've
seen photographic evidence they've been
breaking the rules we've heard about
parties at downing street uh on the eve
of the uh duke of edinburgh's funeral
which is
quite frankly despicable you know all
the evidence is building up and yet
you're still saying let's wait for the
report the prime minister himself has
admitted look we don't know
take take the the the party that took
place on the eve of
of the funeral and completely
unacceptable two parties and you know
who knows two parties i'm sure that's
what's been because that's been reported
and the people involved have apologized
that's what happened completely
unacceptable wrong in every way you know
there's there's no excuse for that at
all should people be disciplined and
reprimand for that of course they should
be but
what happens next we should wait for the
report and for sue to be able to speak
to people that may have gone to the
party may have known about the party
may have any information they can shine
on it let her put that together and
present that information to the british
public and to the parliament and then we
can make a job so we're very cross about
those parties but we won't acknowledge
that the prime minister broke the rules
at another event why why are we
cherry-picking which events that we um
agree with and which we don't i don't
think we are a cherry-picking this this
report can go anywhere sue can look at
anything they're they're so we're we are
rightly we're talking about things that
we know or have heard about because
they've been reported but the purpose of
this report is to have an independent
investigation that where all the
information is provided she can speak to
whoever she wants and establish that
yeah you are in the runners and riders
um let's have a quick look just before i
let you go we're out of time but your
name has been put forward as one of
those who has got a very distinct chance
of running as the next prime minister of
this country what do you think of that
what i think is that there is no
leadership election and this is what all
there is
lots of lots of lots of uh speculation
you like the picture do you think it's
not bad actually yeah it's almost prime
ministerial some might say well they all
look you know look at look at that you
know there's a good good lineup of
talent i would say in the in the party
there and uh so but there is no
leadership election we've got a prime
minister he's getting on with the job
and that's what matters and when there
is you might dance here
there is no leadership election good to
talk to you as always thank you very
much steve for joining us